blue food coloring can be oxidized by
household bleach which contains
hypochlorite ion or ocl - to form
colorless products as represented by the
equation above so we have this equation
this equation where we have blue food
coloring which has this chemical formula
and it's reacting with bleach or
hypochlorite and it's making colorless
products so we're getting this color
change from blue to colorless a student
used a spectrophotometer set at a
wavelength of 625 nanometers to study
the absorbance of the food coloring over
time during the bleaching process in the
study bleach is present in large excess
and I will underline that because that's
important it's a present in large excess
so that the concentration of
hypochlorite is essentially constant
throughout the reaction the student used
data from the study to generate the
graphs below so we'd like to answer part
8 and Part A based on the graphs above
what is the order of the reaction with
respect to the blue food coloring so we
have a lot of information here you have
these three graphs here we have if we
write absorbance as a we're looking at
the concentration of a over time we're
looking at the Ln of eight over time the
natural log and we are also lastly
looking at one over the concentration
eight over time so we would like to know
what is the order of the reaction with
respect to our blue my first instinct
when I see this problem is actually to
be a little bit panicky because hey we
have we have a lot of information here
so how do we deal with it we also have a
little bit more information for this
problem we also have the equation sheet
so this is a part of the equation sheet
that's relevant for this problem so it's
all of the equations that have to do
with kinetics which is looking at
reaction rates so that is what we're
looking at here
so we have three possible things that
might be helpful for this problem maybe
not right so we have this first equation
which gives us the first order
integrated rate law we have the second
equation
which gives us the second order
integrated rate law and we have this
third equation which is actually an
equation for the half-life so it's
saying half-life is 0.693 divided by K
and that is a half-life for a
first-order reaction and the important
thing to remember here which will come
up again in a second is that this is a
constant because K is a constant so our
half-life is also a constant for a
first-order reaction so that's the
information we have let's look back at
our graphs we're gonna start by looking
at just the first graph it turns out we
can get a lot of information just by
looking at the concentration of a over
time so if we look at this first graph
and we look at the concentration of our
blue stuff going down over time we can
see immediately that this is not linear
so the fact that it's not linear
immediately tells us it's not zero order
if it was zero order we would expect to
see a straight line which I will draw
with a dotted line because that's not
actually what we're seeing so it's not
zero order we can also get some more
information by looking at this one graph
we know it's not zero order can we tell
from this first graph if it's
first-order and the answer is we
actually can if you remember from
looking at the equations sheet we said
that first-order reactions so for
first-order reactions we would you know
and I'd say this is maybe one of the
first the most important things about
first-order reactions is that half-life
is constant so that means that the Khans
the time it takes for the concentration
to go down to half of what it was is the
same no matter what your initial
concentration is no matter what point in
your class in your reaction you're
you're at
so that's something we can actually
investigate just by looking at this
first graph we can see how much time it
takes to get to half the concentration
and see if that's something that changes
over time so for example if we start
with 0.8 right here half of 0.8 is 0.4
so we can see how much time it takes to
get from a point eight two point four
which is right here and if we let go
down we can see it takes 20 seconds to
go from to go to have the concentration
from point eight starting at point eight
absorbance units we can look at the
half-life now to go from point four two
point two so if we go from point four to
point 2 and I will change colors
so going from 0.4 to 0.2 takes another
20 seconds and so we can do this again
and again we could go for point two two
point one we'll just see the
continuation of a pattern here which is
that we can see that it always takes
twenty seconds to have the concentration
and so the fact that half-life is
constant based on graph one immediately
tells us that our reaction is
first-order because or half-life is
constant we don't even have to look at
any of the other graphs there is another
way you could do this problem you might
remember based on the equations that we
have or based on just equations you know
off the top of your head so one reason
we know and one reason we could say this
is first orders because P 1/2 is
constant the other reason why we know
this is first-order is when a reaction
is first-order in your reactant you know
that graphing Ln of your reaction versus
time gives you a straight line and we
can see from graph two that this is the
case
so we have these two pieces of evidence
from graph one and graph two that tell
us that this particular reaction is
actually first order with respect to the
blue food coloring